CHRISTOPHER WRAY.
IN RESPONSE TO THIS GAPING
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT INSPECTOR
GENERAL REPORTS.
WILL BRING IT TO YOU WHEN IT
HAPPENS.
AMONG THE MANY NEW REVELATIONS,
THE IG REPORT BLASTS FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY FOR HOW HE
HANDLED THE HILLARY CLINTON
EMAIL PROBE, SAYING HE BROKE
PROTOCOL.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS RESPONDING TO
STUNNING DEVELOPMENTS.
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS BRIEFED ON
THE IG REPORT EARLIER TODAY AND
IT REAFFIRMS THE PRESIDENTS
SUSPICIONS ABOUT COMEY'S CONDUCT
AND THE POLITICAL BIAS AMONG
SOME OF THE MEMBERS OF THE FBI.
>> Jesse: "SPECIAL REPORT"
ANCHOR BRET BAIER.
I'M SURE YOU HAVE NOT READ THE
ENTIRE THING.
>> Bret: DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY
TREES WE'VE KILLED?
WE ARE ALL PRINTING IT.
>> Dana: AND I'M SURE YOU ALL
ARE READING IT.
>> Jesse: WHAT JUMPS OUT AT
YOU SO FAR?
>> Bret: THE BIG LOSER: JAMES
COMEY.
THIS IG REALLY GOES AFTER THE
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR FOR HIS
DECISION-MAKING.
TWO, THE OTHER LOSER, PETER
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE AND THOSE
TEXT MESSAGES THAT SURFACED,
MORE OF THEM, AND THIS REPORT.
THE BIGGEST OF WHICH WILL BE I'M
SURE GRASPED UPON BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
SUPPORTERS.
SEVEN WORDS IN ANSWER TO ATTACKS
FROM LISA PAGE TO PETER STRZOK.
"TRUMP IS NEVER GOING TO BECOME
PRESIDENT, RIGHT, RIGHT?
WE WILL STOP IT.
THAT, IN AND OF ITSELF EVEN
THOUGH WE DON'T HAVE THE FULL
CONTEXT, JUST THAT IN A VACUUM
WILL CREATE MAJOR FUEL TO THE
ISSUE OF WHAT WAS HAPPENING
BEHIND THE SCENES.
THE OTHER THING TO NOTE IS THAT
OVERALL, THE IG SAYS THEY
COULDN'T DOCUMENT POLITICAL BIAS
WITHIN THE FBI ON THE DECISIONS
MADE EARLY IN THE CLINTON EMAIL
CASE.
AND DOES RAISE QUESTIONS,
FIND AND HOW THAT AFFECTS THE
CASE AFTER JULY, WHEN THE FBI
DIRECTOR COMEY COMES OUT WITH
THE NEWS STATEMENT.
>> Jesse: SEEMS LIKE THE
REPORT TEASED UP THE NEXT IG
REPORT ABOUT THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION, ESPECIALLY OFF
THE NEW PAGE-STRZOK TEXTS.
KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE.
>> Kimberly: I THINK THERE WAS
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAYING THERE'S
MIGHT BE SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE IN
HERE.
OBVIOUSLY QUITE VOLUMINOUS.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE LEVEL OF
DISCUSSION THAT PRECEDED THIS,
DO YOU THINK THEY TAKE AWAY,
WHAT YOU ARE HEARING FROM BEHIND
THE SCENES, IS THAT THIS WAS
SOMETHING THAT THEY OVERPROMISE,
AND ARE DELIVERED.
HOW WOULD YOU CHARACTERIZE IT?
>> Bret: FIRST OF ALL,
DEPENDING ON YOUR POLITICAL
POINT OF VIEW, JUST TALKING PURE
POLITICS, YOU LOOK AT THIS AND
THERE WILL BE PEOPLE WHO SAY
IT'S A NOTHING BURGER AND OTHER
PEOPLE WILL SAY IT IS CHOCK-FULL
OF DAMNING THINGS.
I THINK WHAT YOU WILL HEAR FROM
CHRIS WRAY IS THAT THIS IS A BIG
PROBLEM WITHIN THE FBI.
THEY ARE PROBABLY GOING TO
ANNOUNCE SOME KIND OF ACTION
THEY ARE TAKING.
IF YOU LOOK AT TREY GOWDY AND
WHAT HE PUT OUT IN THE STATEMENT
HE PUT OUT, HE SAYS HE IS
ALARMED, ANGERED, AND DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTED AND GOES ON TO
DETAIL AND PRETTY SCATHING TERMS
WHAT HE SEES.
HE IS A GUY WHO HAS DEFENDED THE
FBI, EVEN THE MOST RECENT
SPYGATE STUFF.
>> Jesse: JUAN WILLIAMS TOOK A
REALLY GOOD DATA TAKEOFF.
WE HAVE MARIE HARF IN HIS PLACE.
MARIE, TO GET AWAY.
>> Marie: JIM COMEY RESPONDED
WHERE HE ENDORSED THE IG'S
EFFORTS BUT DISAGREE WITH SOME
OF THE FINDINGS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS NEXT FOR
JIM COMEY?
DOES HE KEEP SPEAKING OUT?
DOES HE KEEP QUIET?
IS HE INVESTIGATED FURTHER?
>> Bret: I BET HE GOES INTO
THE NIGHT.
IT'S INTERESTING HE'S OUT OF THE
COUNTRY AT THE TIME THAT THE IG
REPORT IS COMING OUT.
HE OBVIOUSLY MADE HIS ROUNDS ON
THE MEDIA, INCLUDING
"SPECIAL REPORT."
HE DID THE BOOK TOUR, LAID THE
GROUNDWORK FOR HIS DEFENSE AND
OBVIOUSLY HAS THIS LETTER TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ."
BUT THE STUFF IN HERE SUGGESTS
THAT HE MADE SOME BIG MISTAKES
IN THE EYES OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
NO MATTER IF YOU LOOK AT FROM A
CLINTON PERSPECTIVE, THAT THERE
ARE FOLKS HE THINK HE COST
HILLARY CLINTON OF THE ELECTION,
OR A TRUMP PERSPECTIVE AND HOW
HE DEALT WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
AFTER THE ELECTION.
>> Jesse: HE TOOK IT ON THE
CHAIN.
THEY SAID HE COMMITTED SERIOUS
VIOLATIONS OF FBI POLICY AND
PROCESS AND DAMAGE THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE
INVESTIGATION, ANY INSTITUTION
ITSELF.
TOUGH STUFF COMING OUT OF THE IG
REPORT.
>> Dana: BRET, IN JIM COMEY'S
STATEMENT, IN REACTION TO THIS,
FIRST A TWEET AND THEN AN OP-ED
IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES," HE SAYS
I RESPECT THE IG.
I THINK THEY DID GREAT WORK
HERE.
REASONABLE PEOPLE CAN DISAGREE.
HE IS MOVING ON.
NOW THE STRZOK ATTORNEY PUT OUT
A STATEMENT BUT HE DIDN'T
ADDRESS THE TEXT MESSAGES.
I'M CURIOUS IF YOU THINK THAT
MIGHT HAPPEN AND THEN MY OTHER
QUESTION IS MICHAEL HOROWITZ,
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL, HAD A LOT
OF BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FROM A LOT
OF CREDIBILITY ACROSS
ADMINISTRATIONS.
RADCLIFFE SAID HE READ THE
REPORT, HAS BEEN BRIEFED, AND HE
MAINTAINS CONFIDENCE.
MICHAEL HOROWITZ, I GUESS THIS
NEXT IG REPORT ON THE CLINTON
EMAILS THEMSELVES AND THAT
INVESTIGATION WOULD HAVE SOME
CREDIBILITY.
>> Bret: YEAH, AND THESE ARE
QUESTIONS I'M GOING TO ASK
CHAIRMAN GOWDY AND GOODLATTE AND
THEY WILL BE ON THE NEXT HOUR ON
"SPECIAL REPORT," I THINK
THERE'S A LOT HERE THAT TEES UP
THE NEXT ITERATION OF THE IG'S
EFFORT.
THE SECOND TEXT, NO, NO, HE
WON'T BE PRESIDENT.
WE WILL STOP IT.
THAT WAS RELEASED IN THE LAST
FEW DAYS.
THE FIRST PART WAS RELEASED BY
THE SECOND PART WAS NOT.
IT TELLS YOU SOMETHING ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY AND WHERE THIS
DOCUMENT BACK AND FORTH IS GOING
WITH CAPITOL HILL AND OVERSIGHT.
TO YOUR POINT, PEOPLE WILL LOOK
AT THIS AND THERE WILL BE
REPUBLICANS WILL LOOK AT IT AND
SAY HE DIDN'T.
OTHERS WILL LOOK AT IT AND SAY
THERE IS A LOT IN HERE YET TO BE
MINED.
>> Jesse: FROM "THE FIVE"'S
INSPECTOR GENERAL, GREG GUTFELD.
>> Greg: THIS IS BLOWING MY
MIND.
I HEARD A RUMOR THAT THE FBI'S
GOING TO CHANGE THEIR NAME TO
FWB?
>> Bret: THERE IS A SECTION
THAT DEALS WITH THAT.
TICKETS, INVITATIONS.
>> Greg: I HAVE A SERIOUS
QUESTION.
WE FOUND OUT THAT COMEY USED HIS
PRIVATE EMAIL TO CONDUCT
NONCLASSIFIED BUSINESS WHICH IS
MAYBE WHY HE COULDN'T DAMN
HILLARY FOR DOING THE SAME
THING.
EVERYBODY IS GUILTY OF DOING THE
SAME THING.
COULD THAT BE PART OF THE REASON
WHY HE DECIDED NOT TO PROCEED
FURTHER?
>> Bret: YOU ARE TRYING TO BE
FUNNY --
>> Greg: I AM SERIOUS.
>> Bret: THESE ARE GOOD
NUGGETS OF THE REPORT THAT HAD
NOT BEEN PUT OUT THERE.
COMEY IS USING A PRIVATE EMAIL,
EVEN THOUGH IT'S UNCLASSIFIED,
TO DEAL WITH THE EMAIL
INVESTIGATION OF HILLARY CLINTON
INVESTIGATION OF HILLARY CLINTO
HILLARY CLINTON.
THE IG SAYS THAT'S NOT A GOOD
THING.
I HAVE THE GUTFELD DIARIES OVER
HERE, LOOKING FOR THEM.
>> Kimberly: FRIGHTENING.
>> Greg: YOU ON PAGE 70.
>> Jesse: YOU DO NOT WANT TO
BE ON GUTFELD'S DIARY.
NICE JOB OF THE DAY WITH THE
INTERVIEW WITH THE PRESIDENT.
WE WILL BE LOOKING FORWARD TO
6:00 P.M. FOR ANOTHER GREAT
"SPECIAL REPORT."
KIMBERLY, IT'S LIKE WE TALKED
ABOUT THESE NUGGETS COMING OUT.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE PROBABLY
ANOTHER 24 HOURS TO GET ALL OF
THEM, HER EMAILS WERE PENETRATED
BY A FOREIGN AGENT.
THAT, WE REALLY DIDN'T KNOW
BECAUSE COMEY HIMSELF SAID IT
WAS POSSIBLE THAT HAPPENED IN
THAT WE LEARNED THAT IT ACTUALLY
DID HAPPEN.
ONE OF THOSE EMAILS WAS
CONSIDERED SECRET, WHICH MEANS
DISCLOSURE OF THAT EMAIL
REASONABLY COULD BE EXPECTED TO
CAUSE SERIOUS DAMAGE TO THE
NATIONAL SECURITY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Kimberly: I THINK THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT, MUCH WAS MADE AT
THE TIME, POSSIBLE BUT THERE WAS
NO NAILING IT DOWN.
OBVIOUSLY THEY KNEW AND WERE NOT
HONEST ABOUT IT.
ESSENTIALLY I CALL IT A
COVER-UP.
IF YOU KNEW THEY HAD BEEN
PENETRATED AND HAD BEEN READ, BY
OR ACCESSED BY A FOREIGN AGENT,
THAT'S SIGNIFICANT.
IT'S A SECURITY BREACH OF THE
HIGHEST ORDER AND IS VERY
DISCONCERTING FOR US FOR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
BUT THERE YOU GO.
HILLARY CLINTON, THE RULES OF
LOG DO NOT APPLY TO HER OR
MR. COMEY.
BIRDS OF A FEATHER.
>> Jesse: MARIE, SOME OF THE
NUGGETS I AM INTERESTED IN DEAL
WITH STRZOK.
THEY KEEP COMING.
"WE WILL STOP IT," MEANING WE
WILL STOP THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
COMPARE THAT WE NEED TO PROTECT
THE COUNTRY FROM DONALD TRUMP
AND WE NEED AN INSURANCE POLICY
IN CASE HE'S ELECTED AND NOW FBI
AGENTS ARE CALLING TRUMP
SUPPORTERS RETARDED.
THEY ARE EXCHANGING ANTI-TRUMP,
PRO-HILLARY TEXT MESSAGES.
THE IG SAYS THERE WAS
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE OFFICIAL
ACTION TO IMPACT TRUMP'S
ELECTORAL PROCESS         PROSPC
ELECTORAL PROCESS         PROSPS
ELECTORAL PROCESS         PROSP.
FOR THAT
SEEM SERIOUS.
>> Marie: I THINK THEY
DEMONSTRATED INCREDIBLY BAD
JUDGMENT.
BUT THEY ALSO FOUND THAT NO
EVIDENCE OF POLITICAL BIAS
AFFECTED THE HILLARY EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
THESE PEOPLE SHOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN DOING THIS.
IT WAS STUPID AND IT LOOKS BAD
ON THE IG FOUND THAT, IT LOOKS
BAD, CALLED INTO QUESTION THE
INVESTIGATION IMPARTIALITY.
BUT THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF THEIR
PERSONAL VIEWS IMPACTED.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE NOT DUMB
ENOUGH TO LEAVE A PAPER TRAIL.
YOU >> Marie: YOU HAVE BEEN
WAITING FOR THIS REPORT AND
PUTTING A LOT OF FAITH IN WHAT
COMES IN IT.
>> Jesse: I THINK WE HAVE BEEN
WE SAID IT WAS PROBABLY GOING TO
BE A BIG AIR BALL.
>> Marie: THIS IS SELECTIVE
HISTORY, FAKE NEWS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THEY
DID NOT FIND EVIDENCE OF
POLITICAL BIAS AND IMPACT OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
THEY ALSO FOUND THAT THEY HAD NO
WAY, NO ABILITY TO PROSECUTE
HILLARY CLINTON UNDER THE FIVE
STATUTES THEY EXAMINED.
I AM NOT IN A TREE BUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE LOOKED
INTO THE QUESTION THAT A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS AND TRUMP SUPPORTERS
KEEPING ENOUGH AND FOUND THAT
THEY DID THE RIGHT THING.
>> Jesse: WITH THE IG REPORT
SAYS IS THAT WITNESSES, MANNING
PROSECUTORS OF THE DOJ OR FBI
INVESTIGATORS, DIDN'T THINK THAT
THIS WOULD BE A PROSECUTABLE
CASE.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THE IG CONCLUDED
THAT WAS THE FACT.
IT JUST MEANT SOME ATTORNEYS
DISAGREED.
>> Dana: TO FURTHER THAT, I
THINK WHAT ONE OF THE THINGS
COMEY DID.
THE IG SAYS INSUBORDINATE,
INSUBORDINATION.
WHO DID THAT BENEFIT?
IT BENEFITED LORETTA LYNCH, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE TOOK IT OUT OF HER HANDS FOR
MAKING A CHARGING DECISION THAT
I'M SURE PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
LORETTA LYNCH DID NOT WANT TO DO
TO THEIR NOMINEE.
THIS GETS ME BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL POINT OF HOW DO WE KNOW
ANY OF THIS?
WHY HAVE WE SPENT SO MUCH TIME
AND SO MUCH MONEY ON ALL OF
THIS?
IT GOES BACK TO
HILLARY CLINTON'S DECISION TO
SUBVERT THE PROCESS, TO HAVE HER
OWN EMAIL SYSTEM FROM A HAVE A
PRIVATE SERVER.
THAT WAS IN 2015.
WE HAVE SPENT 500 PAGES.
IT'S NOW 2018.
WHAT YOU MIGHT SAY IS AT LEAST
SHE UNCOVERED THE STRZOK AND
PAGE EMAIL SITUATION AND THEIR
BIAS AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: WE HAVE BEEN MOVING
BACKWARDS FOR A LONG TIME.
>> Greg: I REMEMBER WE SAID, I
DON'T KNOW WHEN IT WAS, SHE WAS
TALKING ABOUT GENDER.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE FEMALE.
IT'S ABOUT THE EMAIL.
THAT'S WHAT WE KEPT SAYING.
A COUPLE OF POINTS.
HOW AMAZING IT MUST NEED TO BE
ANTHONY WEINER.
HE MIGHT BE ONE OF THE FEW
PEOPLE WHO IS HAPPY HE IS IN
THE FACT IS IF IT WASN'T FOR HIS
LAPTOP AND HIS LAP, TRUMP
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ELECTED.
HE KEPT -- WE SHOULD BE THINKING
ANTHONY WEINER.
HE KEPT HILLARY OUT OF OFFICE.
IT'S REALLY ABOUT HIM AND HUMA.
MORE EVIDENCE DONALD TRUMP CAN
TURN PEOPLE INTO EMOTIONAL
HIGH SCHOOL FRESHMAN.
STRZOK AND PAGE WERE LIKE
CHARACTERS IN THE DAVID BOWIE
SONG "HEROES."
UP AGAINST THE WALL.
THEY ARE GOING TO DO ANYTHING
THEY CAN.
SO DEEPLY EMOTIONAL FOR THEM.
THEY WERE LIKE STAR-CROSSED
LOVERS IN A ROMANTIC SONG.
>> Kimberly: HOLLYWOOD
STARLETS.
>> Greg: I THINK IT IS WEIRD
TIMING THAT THE DAY THIS REPORT
COMES OUT COME OF THE MEDIA GETS
A GIFT IN THE STATE OF NEW YORK
SUING TRUMP OF THE TRUMP
FOUNDATION.
IT'S INCREDIBLY WELL PLAYED.
>> Jesse: IT'S JUST A
COINCIDENCE.
>> Greg: NO, IT'S NOT.
PARTY AND MEDIA WORKING
HAND-IN-HAND.
TO ME IT IS SO OBVIOUS AND
WRONG.
>> Jesse: IT IS.
THEY SAT ON THESE EMAILS FOR A
MONTH.
STRZOK WAS BEHIND THE SLOW
WALKING TO JAMES COMEY'S OFFICE.
>> Kimberly: IT'S REALLY SAD,
ISN'T IT?
YOU READ THIS AND BECOME A MOST
DESENSITIZE BUT THIS IS REALLY
EGREGIOUS.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THE FBI,
HELD THE HIGHEST REGARD IN TERMS
OF JUSTICE AND SUPPOSED TO BE
TRUTH SEEKING AND FACT FINDING
WITHOUT ANY IDEOLOGICAL BENT.
YOU SEE PEOPLE HERE THAT WERE
HELL-BENT ON UNDERMINING THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND PREVENTING A
PRESIDENCY.
YOU SEE A CANDIDATE IN
HILLARY CLINTON THAT COMPLETELY
DISREGARDED THE LAW, THE
EVIDENCE, AND REALLY JUST
CREATING A SITUATION THAT
UNDERMINES CONFIDENCE NOT ONLY
IN OUR POLITICAL PROCESS AND
CAMPAIGNS AND ELECTIONS BUT IN
OUR HIGHEST INVESTIGATORY
AGENCIES.
YOU ARE SEEING A MODIFIED,
REDACTED REPORT BY ROD
ROSENSTEIN WHO IS ALLOWED TO DO
THIS.
HE IS ACTUALLY IN THE MIDDLE OF
ALL THIS.
HOW IS IT COMING OUT THIS WITH
CLEAN HANDS?
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT ALL THE
EVIDENCE IS BECAUSE SOME OF IT
HAS BEEN REMOVED.
>> Jesse: I THINK SOME MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS ARE TRYING TO
REQUEST THE ORIGINAL DRAFT OF